hello hi what's up everybody this is
Dave Pelz I'm Kate Quigley I'm really
happy because I have my BFF co-hosting
with me today Jen you're here all the
time now it's Jennifer stirred your
everyone I think you're too drunk to
remember to book guess that's kind of
part of what happened so I hit up Jen
and I just go hey just come [ __ ]
with me for an hour tomorrow exact
someone here but I like it because you
know all my deepest darkest secrets and
I call you on your crown yeah which I
don't like sometimes I won't like she's
honest my father called me and my dad
was like you couldn't make it 30 days
out [ __ ] I was like dad don't listen
my show anyway so and I didn't make it
this week either but we'll talk about
that but everything is fine I've given
up on the 30 day challenge and I've
decided sex is more fun than not having
sex that's talked about this I'm so
excited to have you here so this guy is
amazing I want to read all your credits
but there's like 40,000 I don't even
know what they send you well let's see
this is what I have you co-host a
podcast called SDR which is hugely
popular with big Jay oakerson you have a
show called the tour bus which is a
metal show show about 50 stations around
the country okay you got that he also
writes a sex and dating column which I
love obviously that's a great fit for
this for social underground and you have
this Cruise coming up that I know
nothing about that I want to hear all
about the ship fraud yeah I do two
cruises a year that's one of them that's
so dope so how do you do ship rocked and
I was doing the Motorhead cruise but
where do they take off like out of
usually Miami sometimes Fort Lauderdale
but years ago one of my parents were
going on no way they're all about
locking themselves on a boat why wait
Ralph Sutton everyone I didn't even get
his name out Robin we can follow him and
I am Ralph Sutton on everything and he's
incredibly attractive for people who
can't see you're very cute you are feel
today
really I've been up since like 6:00 a.m.
and you look amazing oh thank you so
much you're from new you
be happy to break your 30-day challenge
with it yes thank you it's already been
broken too Phil Ralph in and the
listeners know this two weeks ago on
this show I I've had it with guys
because every guy makes me a side chick
and I keep [ __ ] guys thinking that
they actually want to date me and then I
find out they have girlfriends and
babies that's like my mo the last how
many guys like six guys or something I
think she's going on five or six at this
point yeah I was like he's European so
there's a little bit of a language
barrier but he's like everyone has their
luggage Kate he got his baby luggage was
the baby's name Samsonite yeah hilarious
yeah so I decided I was gonna go 30 days
without having sex and I made it six
days six yeah but it wasn't my fault
because I ran into a really hot asphalt
well kind of my vagina slept in foul on
to my friends it was a friend hookup I
think you need to buy a jet ski
Ted cuz when Kate wrote a jet ski she
wasn't banging anything who she was
literally like it's just her hitting the
jet ski
I wasn't banging because I had a bruise
the size of Mars on my [ __ ] after I
rode the jet ski she showed me I tried I
mean you guys are too young but jet skis
before they were wet bikes like they are
now yeah they were the stand-up and
those were very hard to get up on if you
had never done it before and I was
trying for anything 20 minutes to get on
one I kept falling off but finally I got
up but you would like kind of drag your
body with it when he got enough yeah
speed you get to your knees and then
you'd stand like it was good oh it was
like a standing scooter that's how jet
skis were originally and water segways
now they're just um they're water bikes
they're not jet ski he's like a ski but
the water pressure after like the 20th
time he's trying to get up I finally
stood up but the water pressure had
pulled down my bathing suit so I was
standing naked know what I was so happy
to finally be standing I was like [ __ ]
this I'm just gonna ride with my dong
out
we're not stopping this thing it took me
25 min did you know it was out yeah or
you could tell yeah for sure my pants
are on the cops one time I don't know if
I ever told you this story
so do you periscope at all around for
you on hello I can't I try just can't do
it I thought there was an I'm bad I try
I just I just can't do it I just well I
like pretty often and when I was at Lake
Tahoe last winter I decided to periscope
doing a polar bear dip into Lake Tahoe
did I ever tell you about this no okay
so I didn't have a bikini I forgot to
bring a bikini it was like January so I
went to Ross to buy a bikini and they
didn't have any because it was winter so
I bought like little kid panties like
under ooh type things and then like a
sports bra and I was like I'll just go
in that so I go out to the the lake I
have my friend who's a comic like
periscoping this for me I take
everything off down to my sports bra on
underwear and I go running into the
water do this Polar Bear Plunge and I
don't realize were there other people
there it was well it was just at the
beginning it was me into comics that was
it it's just the three of us no one else
saw it but so what happened is I start
running into the water thinking it's
gonna be deep and I'm gonna be able to
dive in it's only like two feet deep for
like a hundred yards running waiting to
dive finally it gets deep enough to
where I can kind of like dive in plunge
it's still like four feet by the way it
was so not deep and then I get up and
I'm running back and I'm freezing it's
so cold right a cruise ship like a tour
boat pulls up to this dock while I'm
running in and starts unloading so now
there's like a hundred but what I didn't
realize because I was so cold
is that my sports bra when I dove had
come up over my chest so I'm running to
shore with my tits out couldn't feel a
thing because they're frozen solid
periscope was copper never said anything
you couldn't tell because I was like a
hundred yards out because all the people
on the dock were cheering for me and I
thought they were just like go girl and
then I got to shore and then I rise my
tits are out and I put them away real
quick and then I had to delete the
periscope and everything I could get
throw it off a periscope for news yeah I
just I had no idea it was really
embarrassing and then everybody off the
cruise ship coming off the dock was like
yeah so I handed my number out to all
I'm sure yeah so Ralph you live in New
York I do and you're in LA visiting for
the week yeah but the maintenance visit
a couple of friends and I do like a
bunch of shows all I'm here yeah you're
promoting this cruise right morning
Shiprock talk about the cruise I know
nothing about it okay so it's been going
on now eight years it's about five days
Monday to a Friday it's 15 20 bands and
4,000 people on a boat from Miami to
this year Turks and Caicos and this year
it's Papa Roach Sevendust alter bridge
about about 15 bends I'll Breaking
Benjamin and a few others but we know
over the years it's been corn and just
Godsmack Oh every single day definitely
I wouldn't even make it 30 hours on that
cruise what uh when is it
January 18th to the 22nd it's actually
currently sold out but there is a
waiting list because people cancel sure
every year there's no people now yes
without that should be there will be at
least like 50 to 100 cancels no way yes
it'll get people on I want to go we
should go how fun would that be
could you matter one of us a lot
whatever I'm just gonna be sitting there
and she is well know I love rock I don't
love watching Cates let out but here's
the thing I love guys with lots of
tattoos and piercings and like yeah I'd
have done a lot like this one in this
one in this you mess with the next one
like we'd have to tranquilizer what's
your background Ralph if you ever been
in a band everybody know I mean I'm a
real
bad guitarist on a good day but I've
worked in the music industry since I was
a kid you know he's a strip club DJ for
a long time I ran I ran up I have a food
background I just have I have a lot of
odd backgrounds but I've worked in rock
clubs for a long time oh wait you said
you have a food background yeah I went
to cooking school and ran it for
restaurant for about five years I know
right are you single yes I am oh [ __ ] I
don't hear more about this where'd you
grow up Brooklyn Brooklyn Brooklyn
Manhattan how well do you know Brooklyn
I lived in Brooklyn for several years
well the area is called Gravesend near
Sheepshead Bay okay Kings Highway in :
haven't you yeah I was just over there
for the WBC World Baseball Classic oh
that's a lot of fun Coney Island yeah
Coney Island I went to school near Coney
Island Coney Island's creepy now it is
it used to be really cool when I was a
kid really what is it I've only been
there once and it was I think it was
winter and everything was kind of closed
that's kind of cool trying to make it
nice again but all right they're trying
but you'd still have to like kick all of
the things living on Coney Island out of
Coney on the planet very Russian
it's very much like that Instagram
you don't follow look at this Russian on
Instagram you really shouldn't Kate on
to it and now she's obsessed followed me
back it was like the highlight of my
year I was like they're following me
back I send them things two dudes with
adidas signs carved into their hair I
used that as a barometer when I date
guys one night I was with the guy I
swear and after we hooked up we were
like scrolling through Instagram and I
was like oh my god this feat is so funny
you have to follow I start showing him
photos laughs I don't get it why do you
think this is so funny and I was like
yeah never be like you might as that's
disgusting like how it is the the
second-largest Russian population in the
world really yeah Brighton Beach area
huh number one Russia Russia no I didn't
at all today's I'm just proud of myself
for being awake if I'm being honest I so
okay so you're single have you ever been
married
no but I've had a couple of long-term
relationships and I've had three women
proposed to me
like isn't that I don't know like I feel
like that's the guys job I agree it is
weird how does that happen three
different stories one was a girl just
asked me can we please go ring shopping
which was like a flat-out it was that
takes balls another was a girl that was
she said I've realized that I don't want
to spend the rest of my life anyone else
but you do you feel the same way and I
said I'm sorry I don't
oh I'm not gonna lie oh my god that was
weird
yes the girl was like just dropping
hints that she thought it was time for
us to get married there's only like
three months into our relationship whoa
that's crazy
yeah Ellen was just weird that's just
you know I have a firm belief that
there's a three-month rule that you
can't date anyone seriously unless
you've casually dated for three months
at least yes because everyone puts their
fake foot forward and that people
pretend to be much cooler and not sure
than they are and then you find out
things like they're married they have
kids they're racists or whatever it is
babies more babies girlfriends more
girlfriends story in my life yeah so
maybe take three months or just look at
his Instagram like a no aversion at
least I tribal this is my problem
because I'm so anti stalker because
she's like I want to learn about the
person the old-fashioned way like no
it's not it's true today
it's this is the thing I don't like to
look at guys social media or Google guys
because I just know myself and I know
how crazy my tendencies are to assume
the worst so I might just see a photo of
him but so I'm the girl that would see
like a photo of you with your arm around
your sister and like be like who the
[ __ ] is that girl I'd rather just not
see it and then not be wrong but have
you when you are dating these guys do
you ask them flat out are you single
sometimes yes okay we're trying now
because I'm always want to believe if I
will ask and make sure but because I've
had women live that were married and you
know it's been horrible experiences you
know but if you ask someone if it's a
good you have to take them at face value
well it's
thing now because here's my thing I
never asked if they were single because
to me I assume if they're trying to date
me or at least I mean you might be
dating other people but I assume you're
at least not in a serious committed
relationship it's unfortunate that most
people are horrible people I really do
it is it is but you know what I'm trying
a new thing where I'm so overly honest
now that I'm scaring guys off I don't
care really so like okay let me ask you
this how do you meet girls like when you
meet so I work at home a lot because I
have up my podcast and my radio show
I've built a small studio in my
apartment I do it all there so I meet
honestly on Facebook on Instagram not on
Twitter as much Facebook and Instagram I
find better really much easier because
and there's more you could see common
friends you could see if you have any
and also you can see what you have in
common sometimes if they have a show
that they like or you could just easier
I think to amass more knowledge on
Facebook in a quicker amount of time
then you would on Twitter maybe I should
start doing that because I avoid
learning about people like I avoid their
Facebook's maybe it would be better to
kind of like delve into it right like
especially if you you could find out
quickly plus you find out like if
someone you know used to date them it's
nice to know who you have in common so
like if this goes south that's a good
point
you might I lose a nice divorce what I'm
really doing that works so well and it's
kind of a scare I've talked about it on
the article but yeah I've written an
article about is that I'll use tinder
right or bumble in one of those stupid
apps but I never swipe right I look for
common friends on Facebook and if we
have common friends I'll just add them
on Facebook so then they think that I'm
just a normal guy and not a tinder creep
that had just added them on Facebook and
I know they're single but actually
you're super creepy and you're like I'm
not gonna swipe right on this [ __ ] I'm
just gonna add her on face and if she
added me on Facebook then it's on it
means that she probably was attracted to
me cuz she's single and she doesn't know
just add it on Facebook she accepted it
that's a good point I mean if somebody
tries to add me on face at think another
man's request
every time I accept them I'm gonna think
that they're like yeah you think any guy
that's adding on Facebook that doesn't
know you directly is because they want
to sleep with you yeah guys here's my
other theory I don't know I post a lot
of pictures of cats maybe yeah that's it
they're cat lovers Facebook sex I have a
theory too that guys that like your
posts are flirting that no for sure
right no guy likes your posts and if
they like their posts they immediately
think that you are into them it's not
true always because this is what happens
so Kate admit mistake with this guy and
someone like he posted a picture of
something and I passive-aggressively
liked it that's different it's very
obvious that I passive-aggressive can I
say that I don't think guys okay tell me
about what you stand passive-aggressive
I like we think they do absolutely not
see I'm telling you right now I was like
she goes I liked his photo and I go why
he's a dick and she's like no it was
passive-aggressive he's gonna no I think
you have no idea that's what I said no
idea guys do he knows I'm friends with
her and he has to know that I know that
stuff went down no what do you thinks is
loud now her friend wants it so died I'd
never fun wants to bang me that's dating
dumb people Kate because I'm sorry
we live in Los Angeles what do you want
me to do move there's not a lot of smart
guys out here that's why you must have
better luck in New York what's it like
dating in New York
I'm these days have been a serial dater
I haven't had a serious girlfriend
in quite a while I would say like five
years Wow yeah I had a serious
girlfriend for eight years okay before
that and what since then I've just been
kind of dating wait hang on the
eight-year girlfriend never proposed
that's the one that proposed
so after eight years she proposed got
weirder she proposed like five years in
and I told her I didn't want to that she
decided to still date me and hope that I
would change my mind you told her that
you knew she wasn't like the one forever
but you guys are seriously if you were
committed oh yeah we just nasty
you know I've new
wasn't the right one but I loved proof
Kate you can't change people but my
question is do you never want to get oh
absolutely want to get married one of a
kid for sure oh wow just not with her so
why spend eight years someone I don't
know like the truth is that I think
there's always somebody that gets under
your skin and every really like there's
always that one person that you should
have broken up with a long time before
everybody has that in their pantheon
yeah that was mine you know that I
should have just and I should ended it
three years in this is an audio medium
but I'm nodding this another time
looking directly at Kate I'm doing
really well right now I did hook up last
night but I'm proud of myself in the
past 12 hours you're doing really well
well no because I gave up the 30-day
challenge I think it's a [ __ ]
challenge okay not a [ __ ] challenge
it is you know why because here's what I
decided okay last night I hooked up with
my booty call guy I have one booty call
guy hook up Kate Motel six
I just want to say shout out to the
Hollywood motel Sigma because you walk
in and there are towels swans on the bed
or swans oh I think so okay I invite
this guy last night and we're friends
we're like he's the only guy that I've
ever been able to hook up with and be
friends with and not catch feelings for
it's so crazy I've never had that
usually like my quote booty call guys I
don't speak to between sex like I hit
them up like let's hook up they come we
hook up they leave they're usually not
very good that's why I don't like him
but then why would they remain a booty
call they don't for long they never last
for long but this one is well he's a
professional one thing he does he's a
gigolo
he's a porn he's a porn guy oh so he's a
professional sexter sexer [ __ ] I don't
know why I'm trying not to swear today
like as if I never swear on this you
know but anyway so you know he's you
make me a little nervous I must be
attracted to him he's making me nervous
am i blushing he's sweating that's like
a thyroid issue it's also a little hot
in here
but whatever the point is I hit him up
to just hang out as friends and
I wasn't gonna hook up with him because
of the 30-day challenge but then I
decided did you invite him to the motel
6 week no no no she was like there's a
guy living in my kitchen we need I've
never had a roommate before so now I
don't know where to have sex with guys
so that's part of the reason the 30-day
challenge could work because I don't
have anywhere to hook up with them well
now that you know of a motel 6 that's
out the window well I didn't pay for it
and I wouldn't but I invited them to
come have a drink with me at the improv
and then afterwards he was like do you
want to go somewhere and hook up and I
was like we can't go to my place and I'm
not going to your place he lives like
way in the valley and he was like I'll
get us a hotel and I was like if you
want to pay for a hotel I'm down she was
hoping it was the W to the motel 6 and
then the best part is we go in did have
hourly rates it was like a hundred bucks
ok but we go in we get in the room by
the way I'm a huge advocate of hotel sex
I think even if you're in a relation you
know why because you don't have to clean
up the mess yeah and you can like you
can like whip the curtain so but the
best part is he cut his knee open unlike
the corner of the bed somehow they got
the best part there's blood everywhere
story room for like we got there I think
we got there too we left at like 4:30
some hotel clerk thinks you've been
murdered and I could tell the front desk
guy was looking at me weird like maybe
he thought I was a hooker and I was like
hey just so you know he's the hooker not
me I'm something snapchatted a video
hooker pushing you down the hallway and
I was like what is why she hated invited
me out last night and I was just too
tired I was like no I'm like she can go
one night without don't supervision and
the next thing I know I
got this morning and it's Kate sitting
in a luggage dragging like I wasn't that
drunk I only had three drinks last
night's a lot free I know it kind of is
but also I just the reason I did it is
cuz I'm trying to get over someone and I
think the best way to get over someone
is to piss them off and make him jealous
he doesn't even follow me on anything
anymore I'm yeah I just
he doesn't have to follow you how long
me with that guy nobody trying to get
over six month guy Reseda [ __ ] I
shouldn't be saying these six months
yeah well we didn't really we were never
technically together we were just dating
oh no no no that was going on for like
nine months she could have had a baby in
the time that they were you were never
together he never wanted me because he
had a girlfriend that I didn't know
about they all have girlfriends he found
out about when we went to go put peanut
butter under his door handles the other
night property cuz they're too poor
we're like cars gates let's change the
truth is I really am over the other dude
it's just the sex was so amazing I'm
trying to forget about that that's what
I was saying that goes back to what I'm
saying before it's usually that that's
all it is for me I get hooked on amazing
sex and that's because I was married for
ten years I didn't have good sex for
like ten years so now when I get really
great sex it's like finding water in the
desert yeah it's a drug and then it's aw
it's downhill from there and you put up
with so much [ __ ] right I mean I mean in
logical terms if someone was telling you
I'm dating this guy that's married and
doesn't want me you would say to them
what the [ __ ] is your problem just stop
seeing that guy but when it's usually
like this egg's you just put up with
nonsense guys too though right yeah but
I think that as you get older because
I'm older you don't put up with [ __ ] and
it doesn't matter you just you don't put
up with maybe that's what it is maybe
I've gotten to the point where I just
don't put up with anything anymore I
don't think it's age do you know what I
know it's it's experience it's the more
than you deal with something that comes
with age most likely because you've done
and you didn't have any it she didn't
because when you're like 18 or 19 and
you first start [ __ ] and first are
dating you think that that love is so
special and then the more times that you
go through that path the less the more
you realize it's not as unique or is not
as special because it's something that
happens over and over again but see but
you know what I think the difference is
is that and tell me what you think cuz
you're a man in theory it's well I don't
have proof yet but so I think that it's
so much harder to find a guy that's good
in bed than a girl that's good in bed
well I'll tell you why because a guy is
based on physicality only so if a girl's
hot ninety nine percent of the time for
most guys that's enough he's a prop I'm
saying how'd you get older also was yeah
then you start like I was dating for a
while that's like quote-unquote
supermodel okay and she would just lay
there because I'm so gorgeous you should
be thrilled that you're [ __ ] me right
which is fun in the beginning but after
a month I just nothing fun you like do
something [ __ ] and I stopped seeing her
people throws nuts for stop zinger
well it's like that thing they say that
for every hot chick yeah of course but I
mean for guys you know how hard it is in
my limited experience with men I've
determined that only one in ten guys
knows how to actually eat [ __ ] I think
it's so rare that a guy is high you
think that's how guys are terrible at it
it's crazy so when you find one who's
amazing at it you're like I'll put up
with any level of [ __ ] for a year so
on the SDR show my podcast is big J we
did a go down on a girl contest where
both of us had ten minutes to go down on
a girl with a 30-minute break in between
the rule was no kissing and to just
basically focus on the vagina area and
not incorporate too much else oh wow
and then she the same chick same chick
30 minutes apart wait you both did it
and you had three minutes for 10 minutes
10 minutes okay you don't want to be the
sloppy second then there was a 30 minute
break
where she showered I hope ya AJ and then
jaywen and the way was that she was
naked on the bed one of us would go in a
go I'm here and the other one go start
I'm here ten minutes what was the other
dude watching did you film it or is it
just audio we periscoped everything up
until that was about to happen okay
and then we periscope the results I love
it and who won well I'm gonna tell you
the story but here's the story
hey he went second which i think is you
know yeah he did all the hard right on
that number but number two he has a
girlfriend who's bisexual who also got
involved and was making out with a girl
and then see she picked Jay but then Jay
went home she has if she could hang out
and then she ended up blowing me so who
really want you one I'd say you won
where did you guys get this girl she a
porno it was a friend of mine that came
by the show just to watch the show just
shot off the idea and Gilbert Godfried
was the guest that night huh and he just
thought it was nuts that this was
happening and she agreed to it I thought
she was joking
because she agreed to a live on the I
had to take a [ __ ] eating class yeah I
tell you this I host a TV show on the
Playboy channel called undercover it's
like about sex fetishes and stuff but on
one episode we did a class this girl her
name's sex nerd Sandra she's like a sex
columnist she teaches courses on
[ __ ] and eating [ __ ] so I took both
I took both classes hmm just take the
blow job class we actually really
educated by the way in the same respect
most girls give terrible [ __ ] really
most girls have terrible odor
interesting yeah yeah every girl says I
give the best [ __ ] every girl but I
learned so much from the class that I
didn't know like here's something did
you know like your mouth goes over the
penis did you know the guy's boner goes
like two more inches under his skin
yes I didn't know that it's like starts
like two inches
per than his belly yeah just like just
an attachment bones inside of your body
anyway so but in this class they use
pieces of fruit to teach us and what
they teach you how to control stuff how
to go down you mean yeah what did you
use well we use melons peaches and I
can't remember the other fruit but but
melons and peaches so the the peach
thing one of the things that they taught
which this is this important the peach
thing they taught you so if the top of
the peach is like the clip you basically
like they said to anchor your upper lip
they're like anchor it so your mouth
doesn't move and basically they were
like the key is repetitive motion
because most guys what they do is they
like move all over the place too much so
the key is to like find the spot that's
working and stay there but they taught
you to use your upper lip as an anchor
to keep your mouth in place and then I
don't want to brag but my peach came
like four times I've seen in my life is
that a lot of women are different some
girls like a more aggressive yes and
some girls are wanted very soft and very
slow
there is no all things to all people
answer what's the same labor job right
and you just need to kind of work with
the person you're with and take of their
cues to figure out what how do you feel
about a girl telling you giving you
instruction or at all absolutely how's
he can [ __ ] know that's what I think
too I love when guys like say what they
like some guys are just quiet and they
don't tell you and then you're like
guessing but you know another thing they
taught me another thing they taught me
in the [ __ ] cross take this from
ladies if you're listening or men oh man
yeah good point so one thing they were
like some guys like the tip you know
more worked on some guys like the shaft
more some guys like so what they said a
great thing to do is is to get some Lube
or something and tell the guy be like
play with yourself it turns me on or
whatever tell the guy like I never liked
that personally I would say that's what
you're here for
yeah but just for a minute and see what
he does because they're saying if you
watch the way he touches himself then
you know without asking what he likes
the best
and yes that makes sense I thought it
was kind of royal but I think to me
there's something more of a turn on
something won't return on my girl asking
me tell me what you like
yeah it doesn't bother me I like it I
like for guys what do you like just
kidding oh okay here's another thing
this is a gross we're gonna get a little
dirty I'm going that okay but I want to
talk about but stuff just a little all
right okay cuz here's the day this is
embarrassing okay so I'm into it okay a
little buddy
receiving oh I don't mind giving if the
guy likes it but that's one that I don't
know how to like come at it I mean like
for instance would you lick a guy's
[ __ ] I have if they ask but I don't
do that without them being like I like
it I never just am like I'm gonna go and
why do you like it I mean all things on
the table you are yeah okay here's the
question let's say that you're hooking
up with a girl and you put your finger
in her body okay which a lot of girls
like Jen I usually start if I'm gonna go
anywhere yes because you can gauge if a
girl is into it or not yeah a less
invasive way to do it well I don't know
anyone that would turn down a tie I do
I've been with girls that got freaked
out by that really yeah yeah Jen I mean
I can own the only way I can see a girl
getting freaked out about it is if I
shouldn't our door like if she felt like
I don't know me I don't like that
really I love it yeah so if engaging
that is where you would progress forward
further from if they seemed really into
that but what if they're into it usually
but on this specific occasion they think
it might be a bad idea because maybe
your boy so how do you tell
without no but I've had anal sex where
the condom came out with [ __ ] all over
it yeah but ain't no is one thing
because everyone kind of expects that
but what about just a few there do it
happened really yeah happens again look
if you're gonna go there you have to
expect that that might be a result and
you can't get disgusted by it doesn't
gross you out as a guy do I want to be
through am i thrilled that it happened
now but I'm not I wouldn't be super
turned off by it I go wash my hand and
stay away from there but what if the
girl how could the girl be like hey
don't go in there with this tonight
that's all what's the big deal I think
people overanalyze things communication
is so easy and if you just openly
communicate things are so much easier
yeah
the more I which we add the more you
know music you're right well alright
well I'm fascinated with all this what
other crazy stuff do you guys do on your
podcast your probably has done a lot of
crazy things Jesus Christ we tried to
out think each other with what we can do
we've had girls pee on our feet pee on
our mouths we made dildos of our of our
[ __ ] and then [ __ ] a girl in the ass
with it what we've a lot of things wait
you made dildos out of your own dick yes
and then um she picked one and then we
[ __ ] her in the ass with it the reason
why she picked mine it's not really fair
because Jay didn't do it right in his
fell apart so she picked mine cuz it
arrived how did you make the donating
right like create a willy it's a website
and they just selling you a silicone
mold and you make a mold it takes
forever though it's like a two day
process it's not easy I went to a
build-your-own
dodo workshop in Allentown right next to
the bear one just in case anyone's
wondering but my dildo is horrible it's
really a geyser name on I did put my
name on it because I like pain I brand
all my day
hilarious cuz I had a girl that I was
dating at the time keep me hard while I
was putting the thing who you have to
hold it over your penis for like I think
it was like two full minutes why did you
have to lie it does the whole process to
it how do you keep your dick hard with
it I was making a play with my ass and
you know just be fun for the two three
minutes it was weird though I [ __ ] up
the first one no okay and also like have
to shave completely because if your hair
is there it's gonna get stuck in the
mold as you shut anyone not completely I
know I know just whatever but anyway so
that who the whole process was hilarious
Wow and also a girl that's willing to do
that with you for fun she's weird
I think but you she helped you make it
penis mold I would do it right now
someone get some play-doh
forgot my next question oh I know I know
have you ever been in an open
relationship oh sure I've had um dawn to
swing parties I've had five girls in
four girls in me twice in my life there
was a girl I dated for a long time where
only reason for being together was to
have either swapping or with another
girl
oh wow really yeah so in your open
relationships the girls were really into
it yeah they're more usually it's a girl
that's bisexual yeah and so a lot of the
times it would be more bringing a girl
into the mix but once in a while we go
to like a swing club or or a couple's
party kind of thing and hook up with
other people you know have you ever been
to a sanctum party I know that is I just
went to one for the first time it's like
it's like um you know the movie Eyes
Wide Shut one of those like masquerading
yeah you know I've I've been
disenchanted with 90% of the swing
parties I've been to that's what I've
heard why cuz I don't want to be the
best-looking person there you know and I
should feel like I don't want to take my
shirt off versus wow I'm in better shape
than every guy here yeah that was my
thing so I went to this party
and it was really fun honestly it was
really like interesting to see I'd never
been to anything like that before
and so the party is basically it's from
members only you have to submit photos
to get approved guys pay some absurd
amount of money you know I just heard
about this thing that was it was an
article about of it it's in a mansion
somewhere right it's in a different man
yeah it's not as it's not as like but
the thing that was interesting about it
is it it wasn't a loner with a guy I
went with a couple who I'm friends with
but not that I liked I've never hooked
up with or anything like that so they
basically were like hey we want to go to
this party and check it out do you want
to come with us in case it sucks and
everyone is weird then we'll just we can
all hang out there and it's free premium
liquor and whatever so I said yeah
there's any chance that they wanted you
to be a part actually you know it's
funny they told me before they were like
we're not trying to hook up with you we
because we do want to make it weird
we're all really yeah so but I get there
and the guys were tuxes the girls can
wear lingerie or a dress and then a mask
right the girls only were male both the
everybody wears a mask if you want to
you have to bring one you don't have to
wear it the whole time but pretty much
everybody was wearing a mask
I was laughing cuz the only people who
weren't wearing masks were people that
were very famous who obviously couldn't
get laid with a mask on so so anyway but
the thing about the party is it wasn't
like what people would think it was like
a porno party it wasn't dirty like it
was all the girls that were working this
party weren't porn stars they were like
supermodel like tens that just didn't
mind being naked and they weren't
[ __ ] anybody they were just there to
look pretty but most of them but then
every hour the party was four hours long
or five hours long every hour there was
like a live sex show where a girl would
either like maybe two or three girls
would blow a guy or they would be
getting [ __ ] but the thing is the way
they staged it the guys were kind of
wearing like these like capes sort of so
you could kind of see and you kind of
couldn't so it wasn't like even watching
a porn it was almost like watching a
skinemax yeah you couldn't fully see
everything but it was like erotic and
ever and
music was like it was like tribal yes
and there was like incense and [ __ ] I
felt like I was at Burning Man I mean
I've been to flat-out swinger parties
yeah with there was one I went to once
that was like invite only like Shiva
they're all super exclusive and you get
them they all suck for the most part but
one time I went to one where it was
filled who sorry if that was me yeah
filled with like really good-looking
people yeah it was wild to be like in a
group of people [ __ ] different people
and that was pretty crazy that's what
I'm saying this party so every girl was
pretty much attend there were a couple
people that you could tell if the guys
aren't it's unfair to the girl that's my
issue so check this out so I wanted to
go to the next one right so I told my
friend I was like because he knows the
owner I go you should text him and be
like hey you need a few more hot guys in
this thing because the whole party there
was only one hot guy who was there alone
there were a couple that were there like
with a girl and everyone else was just
like old rich guys that could afford to
pay whatever 2 grand or however much
that cost him to get in and so I was
like why would I why not have a
screening process yeah the problem is
that with all these parties is that
their motivation is not the party it's
to make money so they're gonna go with
who's spending the money and that's what
sucks in fact for a while when I was
dating this bi girl and we kind of built
like a group of hot chicks that would
come hang out with us
we were gonna start our own swing event
where we're going to just be people we
knew that were cool and it wasn't gonna
cause a problem but the question is
where do you do it you know so I didn't
want to do to my house right regular
parties like they throw me off where I'm
like oh there's such a mess right you
imagine like that [ __ ] going on like on
your kitchen table no just not worth it
come home any dinner the next day I
bailed on the idea just because I don't
air B&B I don't want to be that guy the
other day yeah where your boyfriend's
parents house watching sports and they
have like a pool and a hot tub with a TV
above it so it's awesome you can like
watch sports no one else is there so I'm
like oh I'm gonna take my top off and
get behind me and we'll get like a cool
topless photo where I'm like watching
sports with no top on whatever I didn't
know there's security camera on the TV
so her boyfriend's parents were like um
you might want to tell Kay for next time
but uh was I gonna say about the same
Capone
sends a message to the owner of sanctum
being like hey do you think I could
maybe come to the next one bring a
couple of younger dudes just so there's
some like guys at the party and they
sent him back a message that said this
is what we send to all guys who ask for
free admission to this party if you
can't afford to buy entrance be a man
and get your [ __ ] together that was the
reply yeah so apparently that's that's
and that's why those parties generally
suck you know just yeah for the like I
always felt when we went to these
parties I didn't want my girl to have to
take one for the team just because the
other girl was hot when the guy was a
mess I even if she was like no no it's
alright the girls pretty like not like I
can't in good conscience say yes I can't
let you follow that grenade for me this
is fascinating to me that even you as a
guy because most guys would be like
great I'm the only guy at the party but
this is interesting that you as a guy
are like no this is [ __ ] cuz I
thought the same thing it's not right
yeah I don't think I want to go again
the whole point for me it was like I was
like oh I could meet some hot guys and
like one time I went to one of these
parties with three girls me and three
girls and by far the the some of the
best-looking girls and I was one of the
better-looking guys right and then this
pretty hot couple comes up to us and
wants to join in our party yeah but then
he says to me listen um my girl wants to
be with your girls and I would love to
be with your girls too but you can't be
with my girlfriend hmm I said well what
is the point of you joining us then we
don't need you in the queer we're fine
yeah on our own right and so then I just
never
yeah like there's no point to that yeah
well that's why I was curious about the
open relationship thing because I've had
a couple guys it's happened to me with
two different guys that they asked me
out we hang out a couple times then I
find out they have a girlfriend but then
they say oh I'm in an open relationship
but my she is does she know exactly so
then I always want to be like okay well
why don't we call her how great would
that be to just make the guy call the
girl on the phone on the next episode of
date fellas there was that the great
Mitch Hedberg line I don't have a
girlfriend I just know a girl who get
really magic like I openly will tell
girls I'm dating other women right now I
don't have a girlfriend
yeah but I'm Danny other one if you're
not okay with that then we shouldn't go
forward a hundred percent that's my I
mean that's the only way to be that's
the obvious to me that's what I say
doesn't work for a girl doesn't work for
girls fine yeah just be honest
honesty is the best policy said it so
many times and sometimes by saying that
to a girl a girl that's not even
attracted to you will be like what the
[ __ ] who the [ __ ] does this guy think he
is that he can tell me that and I've had
girls that weren't that attracted to me
all of a sudden want me more because of
that yeah because it's negging right
just like the word the easiest stupid
thing to say to a girl which is so dumb
that so many girls fall for this my
brother would really find you attractive
you're his type stupid that kind of work
taught me the other night we were out
with a group of guys the other day them
on it though and she told me before we
got there she was like yeah I talked to
this guy about you and he's like he's
like Kate's super hot but I'm just not
into blondes cuz I'm I'm blonde and it's
too weird and I was like that's cool I'm
not into blondes either like I'm really
not as a general rule but then that
night I kind of like the more we were
hanging out I was like that's [ __ ]
now I kind of am like why wouldn't that
go in a bang but just I'm a blonde and
then I was kind of like flirting with
them and then later on my chain you got
to get that guy you got to get him to
want me we got it is really pathetic I
have one more question for you if you
have an answer the show is called date
fails because we always tell like our
worst date story worst sex story you got
any really bad ones I have so many good
tell a couple okay first I'll tell you I
wrote down
remind me of them because I read that
that was your concept of your story but
one that is a quick funny one that makes
me laugh was this is just very recently
I went out of this really hot young girl
too young for me like 23 and she slept
over and in the morning I said how was
that you know how'd you sleep and her
response was you were farting a lot last
night more like they were what did you
say
I just laughed they were like I knew I
didn't do it on purpose I was sleeping
it is really funny though you cohabitate
with someone like like when you live
with like I went like Kody and I living
together you just get to see all the
weird [ __ ] people do when they sleep and
it's so funny to me that's why I don't
sleep if I sleep over do you sleepwalk
no oh I have a sleepwalker that's funny
he took all of our tools and through the
mill that's crazy yeah that's crazy
that's tough Pete in our laundry hamper
because he thought it was the toilet wow
that's sexy
you're so lucky and then he passed out
on the floor so I'm a big took a picture
I say ridiculous things to girls because
sometimes if it's not going anywhere
like you're hitting on a girl yeah and
you could tell she's not really into you
if you say something ridiculous like you
should get a girlfriend and come over
for the weekend either they're gonna say
go [ __ ] yourself show this guy whatever
but if she says no you're already in the
[ __ ] nose own anyway so what's the
difference yeah dig further right so
what you're just more no yeah yeah you
know so recently I said that to this
girl that I met on Facebook and sure
enough she decide she's gonna come over
for the weekend with her girlfriend sent
me pictures girl was pretty they come
over we go out for drinks we're having a
great time you come back to my place we
start fooling around they're both very
drunk I don't drink that much I'm tipsy
but not drunk drunk I go into my
bathroom to come out to a loud noise
they are beating the [ __ ] out of each
other
throwing things in my apartment
screaming and yelling this sounds like
my kind of party now and I go and I try
to break them up
they're both now punching me because I'm
trying to separate them right I bring
one into my bedroom then the other one
into the office and then I go back to
the bedroom the girls passed out I go
back to living room the girls passed out
oh my god right this is [ __ ]
ridiculous now I spend the next two
hours cleaning my apartment right and
then I go to sleep I wake up in the
morning and I tell them listen you girls
got to leave my [ __ ] apartment every
night what they said look you broke
glasses you threw chairs oh my god I
gotta get the [ __ ] so I love how you act
surprised Kate you're gonna eat up under
under doors a guy's door he was the
other night moving on you gotta leave
you know you got you gotta leave and
they lived a couple hours away they took
a train in to come see me and now they
get very upset they don't want to leave
I'm like I can't have you in my
apartment it's just you're too crazy and
then they said if we both [ __ ] you right
now can we stay cause it guy this is
just like that I would have gotten to
the bottom of that why we nice they were
drunk and stupid whoo oh my god it's
just like the bit I talk I do a bit on
stage about how I used to message guys
on tinder and offer them sex but then on
purpose I would act insane to try to get
him to block me and turn me down and no
matter what I would write to them
okay still wanna go but I would be like
I want to put leeches on your nuts and
they'd be like cool what time like
anything I said they didn't care that's
what that reminds me of like these
[ __ ] are crazy and [ __ ] up your
apartment and they left the next morning
anyway
I mean it wasn't like nothing else
happened and they were on their best
behavior so on a first date once this is
a I've said this story in my pockets but
girl was beautiful from Texas and she
was like telling me how she's this rock
chick not that I care but because I make
my money in rock yeah a lot of people
think that I would only date a girl
who's into rock I don't really give a
[ __ ] but she loves rocket oh and we're
going out for food and having a great
time and we're having drinks now it's
probably
believe you should go to two or three
places on a first date nothing at this
point the date was phenomenal when I was
like a Maine gorgeous everything was
cool we're looking face to face talking
she looks over my shoulder at something
behind me first date remember buddy just
says who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] okay
holy [ __ ] and I look behind me and it's
a picture of Jimi Hendrix the Rolling
Stone cover so I say I don't know what's
worse right now that you would say that
word oh my anger it's like she's trying
to be funny or whatever just say or that
you don't know who [ __ ] Jimi
Hendrix's and I just paid the bill and I
left
that's insane crazy huh that is such a
turn-off to me that's like I just called
Jenn the other day I was like this guy I
met this guy the other night really hot
guy successful blah blah blah everything
going for him he asked me out we were
flirting we're texting I'm totally into
him and then and then my roommate went
to like a meeting with this guy
unrelated just happen to have a business
meeting with him and he comes home and
I'm like how'd the meeting go he's like
it was great it was great but he was
like it was weird
he set the n-word more casually that's
hilarious
and I was like really and he's like yeah
and I and I was like in like heart like
a joking like what how did it come up
was he like quoting rap lyrics here's
like no he does Jamie on the radio at
the time yeah and so I was like huh I
don't think I can go out with it like
that's just such a turn-off to me I was
like that was instantly like on the
first date I was in a restaurant and the
girl the waiter came I said thank you
whatever when she goes ah I got to learn
how to be nicer to the help I'm like how
about we start with not referring to
them as that oh my god well you have
great day pal I have so many I don't we
do full two hours on base I should ask
you that right up the front usually
people are like all right just a 30
second one real
on Shiprock last year the two years ago
then I didn't know that well we were on
one date beforehand and she told me she
gets wild and crazy when she's drunk
which by the way means don't go out with
a girl and don't get her drunk because
what happened was I was on stage and I
go to see her in the middle of the crowd
naked wrapped herself in toilet paper
that was when I realized this girl's got
to be out of my [ __ ] room or I'm
gonna get lose my game how you [ __ ]
her yet no dude if I saw that I at least
wanna bang she's gonna be insane about
you I there's more to the story I just I
know you know you don't tell it it's it
also weird because it also has the
n-word in it I don't know if I want to
share that one she was just a disaster
to have it kick her out of my room she
owed like $700 in alcohol after I kicked
her out of my room and then they don't
they were gonna put her in jail because
she had no money cruise jail cruise jail
great by the way so one more time the
dates the cruise how do people find out
about your rock calm is where you could
go and get on the waiting list and me
everywhere it's at I am Ralph Sutton the
SD our show we get about 150 200
thousand listeners a month we were
number one on iTunes comedy a couple
months ago no doubt and the tour bus is
listening you listen nationwide from
Maine to Hawaii anywhere that's
terrestrial rock radio it's three hours
every weekend you're killing it
oh stop it valve Sutton everyone Jen of
course you're amazing always I love you
thank you for being here follow Jen at
Jennifer serger follow me at Kate cue
funny if you want to see me and Jen put
peanut butter under someone else's door
handles this follow us on periscope and
make sure you're listening to all the
podcasts on all things comedy love you
guys bye